das hier ist mein lieblingscurry und ich
zeige euch heute wie ihr es wie im
Restaurant zubereiten könnt es ist
wirklich eins zu eins wie im Restaurant
wir brauchen eine Vielfalt von Zutaten
was ganz wichtig ist wir brauchen eine
paneng Currypaste die gebe ich in ein
wenig heißes Erdnussöl die braten wir
jetzt einmal richtig schön an um sie
anschließen mit Kokosmilch abzulöschen
das lassen wir jetzt einmal aufköcheln
das ist quasi die Basis das ist das was
uns diesen typischen Geschmack gibt
jetzt gebe ich ein wenig Hühnerbrühe
dazu und wieder warm werden lassen und
anschließend hauen wir das die mös rein
Leute ihr hab die freie Wahl also ihr
könnt ihr wirklich reinhauen worauf ihr
Lust habt ein paar Kaffee
liimettenblätter ganz wichtig weil wenn
ihr daran mal riecht das ist einfach der
Curry Geruch und jetzt kommt das Protein
eurer Wahl ins Spiel ich habe hier ein
bisschen Hähnchen funktioniert genauso
gut mit Tofu dann geen wir auch unser
Protein hinzu und Kochen jetzt alles was
da drin ist einfach auf die gewünschte
Konsistenz jetzt geben wir den
aufgelösten Palmzucker und etwas
Fischsoße dazu und fertig ist unser
Curry jetzt nehme ich mir ein wenig Reis
und dann geben wir unser Curry einfach
dazu etwas erdmus noch da drüber
Frühlingszwiebel und wer mag kann noch
ein bisschen teilbasilikum dran machen